um so you start wrapping at 21 you're
probably not too good at first yeah I
want it's like I was mumbling my words
at first I mean everybody's you know
what I'm saying shout out to the label
rap for coming in here with this [__]
ring around Amir anyway yeah um real
professional brought a Scarface poster
and brought a loud phone
um no but you obviously used like at
what point in time did you catch your
wave where you felt like you were in
your pocket where you felt like you kind
of had like gotten a real grip on being
able to do this [__] catching a buzz in
the city you know maybe learning how to
make songs the right way right versus
the right way you know when I started
seeing more
seeing more yeah like traveling okay
like like when you travel you see more
you talk about it you got more
inspiration so I was like yeah yeah yeah
so it's all it is is what you see and
you just put it put it how you living
for real right so it's like
it's really it's ways with them words
you got to use them so how did you get
on uh Gotti's radar I was doing my own
thing and
um it's like a neighborhood hero that I
was looking up to in the streets right
and that was one of the guided people
that he raised
so um he put the book in murder and so
he basically telling me like keep going
like they watching you type [__] like
you're a big homie with somebody who was
tight with Gotti yeah and that was kind
of how yeah yeah he put the word in
and put the word in like they were they
were like look at they were like Who
hide in the city and he broke my name up
so he was like hey bro they're looking
at you they and they start looking at me
but he didn't tell me when they was
coming he was like they just looking at
you man like just keep going I ain't
gonna tell you when they're coming what
year did you sign like how long ago
2018. yeah so you were you were a part
of the uh July 26th the awesome press
conference the CMG press conference last
year when mozzie got announced uh-huh
yeah pretty Mazzy by the way yeah three
Mosley for sure I just wrote him in jail
yeah yeah yeah yeah
great guy uh is it do you feel like
there's because CMG if we think of like
I think I like the Rockefellers and the
bad boys and the death Rose I feel like
the closest thing we have to that now is
CMG yeah the lineup is crazy God is a
hell of a CEO he knows how to sign
Talent he knows how to pick Talent
uh do you feel any pressure
when you look to the left and your right
and there's money bag yo and there's 42
Doug and there's glorilla and there's
mods
like you got yeah you gotta you gotta
well you're playing on the [__]
Yankees low-key you know what you mean
pressure though like is it like friendly
competition are you like ain't no
competition if if one win we all win
that's so I don't look at nobody else
bigger than me or smaller than me you
know what I'm saying like we nicked the
[__] with this [__] all of us so we all
doing our thing we all going hard so
when we popping it you know what I'm
saying we represent Goddard yeah if you
don't say he can really sit back and put
his feet up and be like I could sit in
here anywhere yeah you know what I'm
saying that we gonna rock anything